[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires eu sur
tv5 monde ce matin avec ouest france.fr
nos partenaires avec nicematin.com par
contre et franceantilles.fr qui nous
diffuse en léger décalage france
antilles par rapport au décalage horaire
aux fuseaux horaires aux antilles ont
invité ce matin c'est laurent fabius
bonjour laurent fabius jour merci d'être
avec nous et d'avoir réservé ce matin
votre présence à la télévision vous êtes
nul n'ignore le président du conseil
constitutionnel et cette émission est
enregistrée dans les conditions du
direct
laurent fabius une question d'actualité
tout de suite cela bouleverse la france
un livre dénonce les graves défaillances
d'orpea le numéro un mondial ne l'est
pas de priver on a envie de vous
entendre sur ce sujet si les faits sont
avérés où en est-on dans notre société
cette société qui qu'il est traité ses
anciens de cette manière
j'ai pris connaissance comme tout le
monde de ces informations rapportées
dans ce livre est évidemment le
sentiment que j'éprouve comme chaque à
ses hôtes à grande émotion parce que les
faits qui sont rapportés sont très
graves et en plus ça touche des
personnes qui sont dans la plus grande
des fragilités puisque ce sont nos aînés
alors quoi dire tout simplement le fait
qu'il faut très vite qu' il y ait une
enquête qui soit ouverte sur ces faits
et s'ils sont confirmés il faut
évidemment que des décisions soient
prises mais ça ce n'est pas ma
responsabilité c'est celle des autorités
mais le sentiment qui domine c'est celui
d'une très très grande émotion a lancé
la phase préparatoire laurent fabius de
l'élection présidentielle c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles vous êtes sur ce
plateau avec nous ce matin sur tv5 monde
le parrainage des élus pour les
candidats à démarrer
il y à une nouveauté qui peut peut-être
tordre le cou aux détracteurs du système
actuel qui est que le conseil
constitutionnel a mis en place un site
internet j'y suis allé moi même et il
est bien fait sur lesquelles on peut
voir qui sont les élus qui vont donner
les parrainages et qui les ont qui ont
ils soutenu est-ce que c'était important
pour vous dès le départ 17 entraient
dans cette phase première de la campagne
de poser le problème en ces termes oui
bien sûr parce que le conseil
constitutionnel aux termes mêmes de la
constitution il est responsable
de veiller à la régularité de l'élection
présidentielle et si à des recours c'est
nous qui trancheront et je proclame moi
même les résultats donc il faut que tout
se passe parfaitement bien et la
première phase c'est cette phase des
parrainages alors il ya des textes qui
disent ce qu'on doit faire et ces textes
prévoient que les élus peuvent librement
parrainé et donc il est tout à fait
légitime que les parrainages soient
portés à la connaissance du public et
donc ce site présidentielle 2005 qui je
prends très bien faits permet de voir
qui quel élu par haine qui dans quel
département et c'est donc la formation
est tout à fait transparentes alors ça
n'empêche pas qu'il y à une discussion
mais général sur est ce que le système
des 500 parrainages et bien ou pas bien
ce débat on peut la voir en début de
mandat présidentiel mais maintenant
c'est trop tard de toute manière très
passer par une loi organique exact pour
le changer donc on n'a pas le temps gros
allons maintenant juridiquement c'est
impossible de bouger les choses
maintenant mais comme il ya des
discussions générales sur le principe
peut-être faudra-t-il de faire dans le
futur c'est rediscuter est ce que c'est
le meilleur système est ce qu'on peut le
changer là je ne m'engage pas très bien
le 4 mars à minuit le conseil
constitutionnel donc arrêtera la
réception des parrainages c'est laurent
fabius le président du conseil
constitutionnel qui est notre invité ce
matin en face aux territoires dans un
instant françois-xavier le franc de
ouest france
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier lefranc jour
bonjour ancien rédacteur en chef de
ouest france le premier quotidien du
monde pourquoi venez-vous crois qu phone
très bien monsieur fabius bonjour aux
yeux on a vu il ya quelques heures des
images particulièrement choquant des
images d'élus des élus de la nation des
élus du peuple qui se font agresser pour
les sujets d'actualité et là en
l'occurrence était la question la
question de la pandémie mais ça pourrait
être un tout autre sujet ces images là
on les voit de plus en plus souvent
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à cela
parce qu'on peut considérer que dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre c'est plutôt
inquiétant non seulement c'est
inquiétant mais c'est inadmissible parce
que au site et le mot démocratie vous
avez raison quand on regarde l'histoire
de la politique depuis
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
si la démocratie s'est installée à
progresser c'est parce que la violence a
été extirpé quand vous prenez ce qui se
passait
au 16ème siècle au xviie siècle quand on
avait un adversaire politique ça se
règle est à l'épée et petit à petit
heureusement tout ça est devenu civilisé
et quand on voit que des élus du peuple
quel que soit d'ailleurs leur
appartenance sont physiquement agressé
sept pas seulement un recul démocratie
mais c'est une négation de la démocratie
en démocratie les conflits d'opinion qui
peuvent exister se règle par tout autre
moyen que la violence donc il faut être
vraiment extrêmement fermes sur ce point
je répète les divergences d'opinion
existe mais on ne les règle pas à coups
de pierres ou à coups de batte de
base-ball ce qui n'est pas nouveau c'est
qu'il ya quand même une partie des
citoyens français qui ont le sentiment
de ne pas être entendus il interpelle
les politiques qui les interpellent au
passage aussi les médias de plus en plus
de gens ont le sentiment que leur vie
quotidienne que leurs préoccupations
quotidiennes ne sont pas entendues ne
sont pas écoutés comment est ce qu'on
peut corriger ça oui votre diagnostic et
celui qu'on voit à travers toutes les
huiles d'opinion est parfaitement exact
et ses regrets mais c'est comme ça bon
donc je n'ai pas le remède miracle bon
mais je crois que ça interpelle à la
fois les médias les élus mais ça ne
n'autorise absolument pas pour autant
parce qu'on ne se sent pas représenté
à les casser
la figure de l'élu non pas de la
violence est absolument inadmissible
j'ajoute un point c'est que on voit sur
les études de des politologues qui nous
le montrent que de plus en plus dans les
élections récentes il y à des votes mais
qu'on appelle des votes de refus c'est à
dire des votes qui sont plutôt négatifs
votre contre madame x monsieur y est c
est le risque c'est que ces votes de
refus se transforme en où s'additionnent
à des refus de vote et à partir du
moment où cela existerait les votes de
refus plus les refus de vote s'ils
deviennent majoritaires vous voyez le
problème que s'appauvrir et et c'est une
situation qui malheureusement une écrite
par pas mal de politologues les refus de
vote il faut rappeler qu'aux dernières
élections territoriales ont parlé des
territoires on parlait de l'avenir de
nos régions et nos départements
neuf jeunes sur dix de 18 à 24 ans ils
ont eu à voter est ce qu'on peut
imaginer construire l'avenir du pays
sans les jeunes comment faire en sorte
de les de les ramener au vote sachant
que souvent ils sont passionnés par la
politique selon ils ont l'impression que
ça ne sert à rien de voter oui mais ils
font une distinction entre la politique
les partis politiques et il faut aussi
une distinction comme d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'autres citoyens entre les
élus nationaux et les locaux vous avez
vu ces distinctions qui sont faites et
donc voilà je n'ai évidemment pas de
remède miracle et puis c'est pas ma
responsabilité actuelle mais
je crois que ça nous interpelle tous et
grands tout cas ça ne légitime en aucun
cas la violence je rappelle vous avez
été maire de grand quevilly des maires
aujourd'hui de plus en plus sont aussi
confrontés à des situations d'urgence
c'est tout à fait vrai
et
si vous donnez une anecdote
j'ai été élu local pendant plus de
trente ans et je recevais bien sûr mes
concitoyennes et concitoyens et
m'arrivait souvent à la fin de
l'audience que je leur donnais il venait
pour un problème de sécurité sociale ou
autre pour beaucoup d'entre eux me
disait au revoir docteur non je ne suis
pas docteur mais ça montrait bien la
relation aujourd'hui quand j'écoute tel
ou tel ancien collègue c'est pas ça
c'est si vous ne me donnez pas tel ou
tel avantage auquel j'ai droit à ce
moment là je vais aller badigeonnez le
mur de votre maison ça c'est pas beau de
laurent fabius vous avez été premier
ministre de ce pays à 38 ans vous êtes
président du conseil constitutionnel une
très grande longévité dans cette vème
république est ce que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui votre conviction est ce que
les institutions sont en danger
écoutez c'est vrai que j'ai eu un
honneur tout à fait extraordinaire
puisque j'étais à la fois chef du
gouvernement
présidents de l'assemblée et aujourd'hui
président de la juridiction suprême donc
ça me donne quand même grâce à ces
honneurs un regard sur les choses
je dirais qu'il faut être très attentif
à une indifférence croissante au droit
le droit c'est quand même le pilier de
la démocratie est très souvent
trop souvent
on ne respecte pas le droit et on croit
que la violence peut se substituer aux
droits c'est pas vrai simplement en
france c'est vrai dans notre vaste monde
qui devient un monde de plus en plus
brutale mais ça c'est le contraire de ce
qui est le le
vraiment l'adn de la france qui est
dette le pays des libertés et de la
démocratie c'est laurent fabius le
président du conseil constitutionnel
qu'est notre invité aujourd'hui d'en
face un territoire sur tv5 monde franck
chassagnon qui est directeur de la
rédaction devient occitanie nos
partenaires du groupe la dépêche à une
question à vous poser on passe de cette
crise les institutions à cette crise
sociale qui peut aussi s'inviter dans la
campagne électorale on l'écouté bonjour
laurent fabius depuis plus de deux mois
les ouvriers de l'entreprise sam situé
en aveyron sont mobilisés pour éviter le
démantèlement de leur outil de travail
cette entreprise qui travaillait à plus
de 90% pour le constructeur automobile
français renault a mis la clé sous la
porte
les syndicats dénoncent une
délocalisation vers d'autres pays
européens des personnes aujourd'hui qui
se retrouvent sans emploi sur un
territoire qui est déjà bien sinistré ma
question monsieur fabius vous qui avez
été aux manettes en tant que premier
ministre et ministre de l'économie que
peut-on faire pour éviter aujourd'hui la
délocalisation des entreprises
françaises
c'est une bien vaste question et je me
permettrai pas d'apporter de l'eau telle
réponse à cette situation grave et
particulière
mais c'est vrai que la france qui a été
un très grand pays industriel a perdu
une partie de son industrie on voit ça
et ça ne remonte pas à hier
or et dans ma conviction il n'y a pas de
pays fort et la france doit être un pays
fort s'il n'y a pas une industrie
puissante alors ça passe par toute une
série évidemment de dispositions sur le
plan du travail sur le plan fiscal sur
le plan de la formation sur les prends
des échanges extérieurs ça ne répond pas
pour autant à la question immédiate qui
est ses salariés qui maintenant voit le
mur de vente et je n'ai pas d'autres
choses à dire que de dire que
concertation il faut et c'est très
difficile bien sûr que chacun fasse
efforts pour trouver des solutions
industrielles de formation ou d'emploi
la vie politique française donne
l'impression d'être quand même un peu
essoufflée d'être en tout cas sous
tension est-ce que les territoires de
cette question là elle concerne
évidemment les territoires est ce que la
formidable diversité des territoires
français n'est pas un bon point d'appui
pour réinventer quelque chose pour
redonner du souffle à notre vie je crois
beaucoup
c'est le sens de votre question à la
force des territoires et en particulier
des régions
il y a eu des mouvements de
décentralisation qui se sont opérés il
ya eu au moment de la loi defferre vous
rappeler les années 80 et puis tant
d'autres périodes mais
je ne serais pas étonné si dans le futur
et il y à une nouvelle phase de
décentralisation mais évidemment ça
appartient aux autorités politiques
responsables pourquoi pour donner plus
de pouvoir aux territoires pour donner
plus de marge de manoeuvre plus de
possibilité de décider parce que je
crois qu un des paradoxes de la
situation aujourd'hui c'est que à la
fois
les phénomènes sont de plus en plus
interconnecté que ce soit au niveau
national ou au niveau mondial et en même
temps qu'on a besoin d'autonomie et
d'initiative
et c'est vrai que les initiatives sont
souvent prises par au niveau local c'est
vrai pour les régions départements ou
les communes et il ya des choses qui
peuvent se réaliser au niveau local qui
serait beaucoup plus difficile à
l'échelon national bien évidemment la
france doit être unités mais je crois à
cette dynamique locale et on voit que
même beaucoup d'initiatives être prises
dans les différentes régions laurent
fabius notre invité ce matin cho nuque
et le dessinateur et collaborateurs de
de ouest france à une question à vous
poser sous forme de dessin c'est une
tradition dans cette émission on le
regarde ensemble
monsieur le président vous êtes un grand
amateur d'art êtes d'ailleurs
l'initiateur du festival normandie
impressionniste
et quelque chose me dit que cette
période ne vous emballe pas sur un plan
artistique
la question que je pose c'est avez vous
maintenu au sein du conseil
constitutionnel
les fameuses mesures barrières mises en
place
bien avant la crise sanitaire
oui
je comprends ce dont il s'agit on a
respecté bien sûr les règles mais vous
avez raison de dire que je continue de
m'intéresser activement à l'art et
j'aurai l'occasion d'ailleurs
probablement mois de septembre de
publier un livre sur des questions
artistiques vous me direz c'est tout à
fait autre chose le titre du livre vous
l'avez oui ça s'appellera table au
pluriel mais je ne vais pas levé le
suspense aujourd'hui laurent fabius est
ce que ça vous manque la prise directe
avec le pouvoir exige entendez tout à
l'heure vous hésitiez à réagir bien sûr
à cette question qui venait devient
occitanie du groupe la dépêche pour des
raisons qu'on comprend vous êtes tenu un
droit de réserve est ce que ça vous
manque non je vous ai dit que j'avais eu
la grande chance d'exercer à peu près
toutes les grandes fonctions dans la
république est aujourd'hui maintenant je
suis à la tête du conseil
constitutionnel
donc j'ai ce devoir de réserve
alors vous démange pas de dire ce que
vous n'aurez que des je me regarde je
n'ai pas de dérive thème particulier non
et quand je vois je vais pas jouer les
pacistes mais quand je vois ce que
devient de temps en temps le débat
politique auxquelles j'ai participé dans
le passé
je n'ai pas de grand regret et j'ai le
sens de la litote merci laurent fabius
vous êtes notre invité vous restez avec
nous bien sûr merci françois xavier le
franc rédacteur en chef 2 ou est-ce
france le premier quotidien francophone
du monde dans un instant denis jeambar
de nice matin et sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis jeambar vous êtes entre
autre éditorialiste à nice matin je dois
dire que mon jour le vivre puisque
laurent fabius vient de parler du futur
livre qu'il va publier vous ça s'appelle
une femme sans larmes c'est aux éditions
calmann-lévy il sort le 9 février et je
voulais le souligner merci beaucoup
partir pour les antilles laurent fabius
c'est le principe de cette émission
retrouver laurent boutique et le
directeur éditorial du groupe france
antilles c'est la martinique la
guadeloupe et la guyane france antilles
avec une question sur l'autonomie des
territoires
bonjour laurent fabius lors de la
récente crise sociale aux antilles en
décembre dernier on a vu ressurgir la
question de l'autonomie autonomie
évoquée par le ministre d outre-mer dans
un premier temps puis par le président
de la république alors il est vrai que
vu de paris on a peut-être davantage
penser à la dépendance cas l'autonomie
puisque l'autonomie
est permise par les articles 73 et 74 de
la constitution qui régissent telle ou
telle collectivité ou territoires
d'outre-mer qui leur permet d'adapter un
certain nombre de règles dans différents
domaines pour le président du conseil
constitutionnel
ce débat at-il lieu d'être et selon vous
faut-il rouvrir la question des statuts
de telle ou telle collectivité
d'outre-mer vous avez très bien défini
la question actuellement dans la
constitution il y a deux articles les
articles 73 et 74 qui est définissent
ce que sont les situations de différents
départements ou territoires d'outre-mer
et puis il y à la situation particulière
de la nouvelle calédonie il ne
m'appartient pas de dire s'il faut
changer ces mécanismes juridiques mais
si la décision est prise de les changer
évidemment le conseil constitionnel aura
en connaître parce que le principe de
notre constitution c'est que lorsque une
loi ou une loi organique
est voté il nous appartient nous conte
séquentielle de vérifier si c'est
conforme ou pas à la constitution grands
principes du droit maintenant sur la
question de savoir s'il faut modifier ou
pas les règles actuelles ça appartient
aux autorités politiques et non pas à
l'ajout addition que je préside voilà
c'est un passage de fort de france à
nice maintenant avec denis carreaux qui
est directeur des rédactions du groupe
nice matin qui a une question à vous
poser liés à cette crise sanitaire qui
est toujours est malheureusement encore
dans l'actualité qui pourrait s'inviter
dans la présidentielle denis carot à
nice bonjour laurent fabius le
gouvernement réfléchit à une adaptation
des modalités d'organisation de
l'élection présidentielle en raison de
la crise sanitaire de quelle latitude
dispose-t-il en la matière et de quelle
manière le conseil constitutionnel qui
est chargé de veiller à la régularité de
cette élection exercera t-il son pouvoir
de contrôle
on suit aussi amener loi
il est trop tard pour les modifié
puisqu'il il y a des délais qui sont
prévues maintenant il peut y avoir telle
ou telle mesure de nature réglementaire
comme on dit qu'ils seraient prises par
le gouvernement et à ce moment là une
autorité que soit le conseil d'état dans
certains cas le conseil national tant
d'autres pour en être saisi je sais
qu'il ya une commission qui est présidé
par un conseiller d'état monsieur
compris celle qui a été mise en place à
la demande du gouvernement avec un lien
avec les élus et qui regardent ces
questions pour voir si les dispositions
actuelles sont adaptés ou s'ils
voudraient faire telle ou telle
modification
mais évidemment l'objectif c'est que
tous les citoyens français puissent
évidemment s'exprimer et qu'en même
temps on respecte au maximum les
exigences sanitaires
oui vous avez souligné l'importance
l'importance du droit et le conseil a
tranché cette semaine sur une question
en effet qui concerne la crise sanitaire
la validation du pass vaccinale alors
les spécialistes du droit
constitutionnel débattent de cette
question non pas pour remettre en cause
la question de la vaccination mais ils
disent que la voie qui a été choisie au
fond pose un problème de liberté tout
comme la multiplication des états
d'urgence tout comme l'obligation de se
différencier de se vacciner le
traitement a atteint les été choisie
atteint les libertés individuelles et
rompt le principe d'égalité et certains
expliquent tout en descendent défendant
le vaccin que toutes ces questions là
haut a été levée si on avait rendu le
vaccin obligatoire est-ce que ça animer
vos débats au sein du conseil
constitutionnel sans en percer les
secrets bien sûr alors je vous réponde
sans évidemment infligé aux uns et aux
autres à court de droit mais il faut
quand même
importante question est très importante
il répondait ça me permet de préciser
quel rôle du conseil gros sujet le
conseil social ne fait pas la loi ceux
qui font la loi ce sont les
représentants du peuple français c'est à
dire les parlementaires et le cas
échéant c'est le peuple lui-même paraît
fade bien mais dans une démocratie
avancée comme la france il y a comme
dans les autres démocraties avancées il
y a une règle c'est que la loi peut pas
faire n'importe quoi et que la loi doit
être conforme à des grands principes qui
sont dans la constitution et il faut
bien qu'il y ait des personnes hommes
des femmes qu'ils contrôlent si la loi
est conforme ou pas ces grands principes
et ces personnes c'est nous c'est le
conseil constitutionnel donc on ne fait
pas la loi mais au contrôle si la loi
est conforme aux grands principes alors
revenons en à cette affaire de passes
vaccinale
le gouvernement a proposé et les
parlementaires ont accepté une loi qui
dit
dans certaines conditions parce
vaccinale nous avons été saisis de cette
loi qu'est ce que nous avons regardé
le pass vaccinale évidemment c'est une
atteinte aux libertés notamment la
liberté d'aller et venir bon
donc on le constate maintenant il y à
une autre exigence qui est la protection
de la santé et donc nous avons essayé de
vérifier si l'atteinte aux libertés qui
existe et est justifiée par la
protection de la santé et nous avons dit
nous ne nous reconnaissons pas le même
droit d'appréciation de la situation que
le parlement parce que nous ne sommes
pas au dessus du parlement mais nous
constatons que il n'ya pas j'allais dire
d'erreurs manifestes et donc nous disons
oui nous approuvons nous acceptons le
principe du pass vaccinale tout en
rappelant de notre décision vous l'avez
lu attentivement que dès que la
situation sanitaire ne l'exigera plus il
faudra stopper cette disposition dont
vous voyez on a dit oui sur le principe
on a annulé un autre élément mais c'est
autre chose on a donné des réserves
d'interprétation mais on ne sait pas
substituer aux parlementaires alors vous
avez rappelé votre obligation de réserve
tout à l'heure donc je sais que c'est
difficile de vous emmener sur le terrain
politique néanmoins j'ai quand même une
question qui relève plus de l'analyse
politique du débat présidentiel actuel
on constate que la gauche représente
aujourd'hui dans son ensemble à peu près
25% l'électorat et tout indique que ça
serait confirmée dans les semaines qui
viennent et le jour de l'élection qu'est
ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire de la
gauche pour en arriver là
alors vous avez raison de dire que je
suis tenu à une obligation de réserve
dans même si je suis très heureux d'être
avec vous je ne vais pas profité entre
guillemets pour l'anjou de voulu aller
du débat d'aujourd'hui non j'ai quelques
souvenirs
sur cette question valent écrire un
livre non pas sur ces questions je
n'écris pas sur la politique donc sur
les tables au pluriel alors sur tableau
c'est un tableau très plurielle ça comme
la gauche autres oui mais l'harmonie ne
sait pas où la gauche plurielle savourer
non alors
c'est le stade rennais alors
quand on regarde
ce qui est un élément intéressant
de quelle
obédience se réclament les uns les
autres les chiffres que vous citez sont
justes c'est à dire que par rapport à
une période passée il y a moins de
citoyens et qui spontanément disent non
avec l'avant de la gauche est plus qu
ils se réclament de la droite bon quand
on regarde des intentions de vote c'est
encore différent mais enfin ces chiffres
existent alors certains disent mais ça
signifie que la gauche est morte etc je
n'ai pas à me prononcer là dessus mais
il faut regarder aussi ce qui se passe
dans les pays voisins bon en allemagne
qui est ce qu'il ya des élections ce
sont les social-démocrates en espagne
est ce que te pouvoir ce sont les
sociaux-démocrates exerce donc si on
regarde objectivement les choses il n'y
a pas de fatalité historique mais est il
y a sans doute
un problème
d'incarnation d'expression de prise en
compte de ce que sont les soucis des
français vous croyez je ne peux pas
aller plus loin dans l'année mais
voilà me semble-t-il quelques éléments
mais il faut compléter cela par un
regard international vous les blu ray
vous en tant que non alors ça je n'ai
absolument pas me prononcer là dessus
que
moi je suis sans opinion politique vous
vous pensez pas que en s'intéressant au
fil de l'histoire plus aux questions
sociétales aux questions écologiques
au fond la gauche a tourné un peu le dos
classes populaires qui sont on le voit
aujourd'hui à travers ce qui se passe
sur les questions d'actualité de pouvoir
d'achat préoccupés par les questions de
la distribution je présenterai peut-être
pas les choses ainsi mais je lis bien
sûr des analyses de politologues et
certain nombre d'entre eux disent je
retiens votre expérience sociétale oui
de sociétal c'est très important mais le
social c'est très important est
traditionnellement la gauche était
représentative des couches populaires et
aujourd'hui d'après ces analystes elle
l'est moins je vous reprends cependant
lorsque vous dites mais peut-être une
des erreurs a été de se préoccuper de
l'écologie enfin bon
de consacrer un peu pro à l'écologie
même si je considère que c'est très
sympa le jeu on va en parler très bien
donc moi je considère alors là en tant
que
président de la cap 21 qui allait
vraiment la mère de toutes les batailles
que la question environnementale est
spécifiquement la question du climat
c'est une des deux trois questions
centrales bien sûr non seulement pour
aujourd'hui mais pour demain pour après
ma juste donc ce n'est certainement pas
une erreur de
s'en soucier la question est comment
justement on compte tout cela justement
laurent fabius vous allez présider la
cap 21 et de dire avec des objectifs
extrêmement ambitieux armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
à une question posée à ce sujet eric
bonjour laurent fabius comment
interprétez-vous l'énorme succès du film
donc le coeur qui est considéré comme
une satire de l'inertie des états face
aux risques que court notre planète avec
le réchauffement climatique vous qui
avez présidé la coque 21 qui fixait des
objectifs extrêmement ambitieux en la
matière oui ce film que j'ai vu et
beaucoup de succès parce que à parallèle
est fait entre une météorite qui se
dirigerait vers la terre et puis les
autorités police ne ferait rien ou ne
dissimulerait alors qu' il ya un
parallèle avec le risque climatique la
certitude du changement climatique et le
message implicite du film si j'ai bien
compris c'est attention il faut pas
détourner le regard il faut surtout bien
maintenant sur le fond
il y a et c'est une bonne chose - de
climato-scepticisme que au moment où
j'ai présidé la coop 21 mai il y à ce
que j'appellerais du climato attentisme
ou du climato fatalisme et
singulièrement pas mal au niveau des
gouvernements
la coop maintien c'était un immense
succès parce qu'on a réussi à la fois à
traiter la planète scientifique qui a
fait un travail magnifique la planète
sociétale de plus en plus de gens sont
conscients et la planète
gouvernementales les gouvernements se
sont mis d'accord sur des objectifs et
sur un texte très bien aujourd'hui on
avance sur le plan scientifique les
scientifiques continuent à faire un
énorme travail bon bravo les sociétés je
pense aux entreprises peut-être pas tout
mais beaucoup d'entre elles je pense aux
régions je pense aux villes faut aussi
un très gros travail mais les boues
ernement certains d'entre eux ne font
pas ce qu'ils devraient faire et donc
autant la coop 26 permis sur certains
points d'avancé même si elle était un
peu décevante maintenant nous sommes
engagés dans ce qui va être la coupe 27
en egypte et la coop 28 aux émirats
arabes unis là que les égyptiens ont une
diplomatie qui est extrêmement
performante les émirats arabes unis sont
un pays important et donc mon souhait en
tant que spécialiste de ces questions
c'est que vraiment à la coop 27 ans
l'afrique donc on traite en particulier
les financements en direction des pays
pauvres et de l'afrique et à la coop 28
qu'on puisse avancer dans les
engagements concrets des états pour
faire reculer ce que j'appelais le
climato attentiste c'est laurent fabius
le président du conseil constitutionnel
et père de la coop qui est notre invité
politique aujourd'hui d'en face aux
territoires merci denis jeambar
éditorialiste à nice matin dans un
instant les questions avec tv5monde de
mohamed kaci a tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour mohamed kaci bonjour si vous
accueillir et un peu de partager leurs
avis parce que vous êtes le présentateur
64 minutes et le monde en français
émissions phares de cette chaîne est
maintenant en retrait parce que
d'habitude à votre place sont de jeunes
journalistes et féminine de cette
rédaction qui sont là mais y'a des
problèmes de covin aussi c'est dans
cette maison être qu'à contacter les
maisons illuminées une norme est jeune
goulet merci à laurent fabius y ait une
fonction vous n'avez pas rappelé tout à
l'heure et que vous avez occupé en
france et non des moindres c'est
ministre des affaires étrangères c'était
sous la présidence de françois hollande
et vous l'étiez en poste lorsque la
france s'est engagée au mali c'était en
janvier 2013 le sel qui fait à nouveau
la une de l'actualité avec ce coup
d'état au burkina faso pays voisin du
mali coup d'état militaire qui rencontre
un succès populaire on peut aujourd'hui
le dire comment expliquez vous cette
adhésion populaire
là aussi je ne veux pas me dérober mais
j'ai mon obligation de réserve mais
c'est vrai que
je dirigeais la diplomatie au moment où
nous avons été appelé d'urgence par
le président du mali je me rappelle très
bien le coup de fil qui le donnait à
fond c'est hollande qui était coup de
fil vraiment j'ai le souvenir vraiment à
la fois dans la tête et dans le coeur ou
ce président a dit si la france
n'intervient pas demain je serai mort et
les terroristes auront pris bamako on
est donc intervenue mais l'un des
problèmes très compliqués c'est que
une intervention militaire peut être
utile mais terme elle ne résout pas la
question les questions ne peuvent être
réglés que sur le plan politique l'acier
ne sont pas résolus à ce qu'il faut
songer à partir est ce que la france
doit peut partir sur je n'ai aucune
légitimité à me substituer aux autorités
françaises mais
il est évident que
la question
se pose se posera d'autant que d'autres
interviennent je pense en particulier
à certains noms de forces russes vous
allez revenir cette présence russe au
sahel d'abord en centrafrique afrique
centrale ensuite on a dirigé la ville et
aussi les observateurs en général
étaient
très au courant de tout cela parce qu'il
y a un aspect de la politique russe qui
consiste à être présent sur un nombre de
plus en plus grand des théâtres
d'opérations on l'a vu en syrie on a vu
dans d'autres pays mais pas messieurs
dames et l'association monsieur fabuleux
la france avait dit clairement s'il
s'avère que des miliciens du groupe
bruce wagner entre au mali nous
partirons la france dit aujourd'hui
qu'il ya clairement des miliciens de ce
groupe russe wagner et pourtant elle ne
part pas seule à se ressembler à mal la
légitimité de la parole française sur
des questions que vous posez sur te
demande un représentant du gouvernement
lorsqu'il viendra voter est ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour l'intégrité physique
emmanuel macron indique la seule
priorité c'était l'intégrité physique du
président renversé roch marc christian
kaboré on vient de le voir à l'image
avec emmanuel macron vous dit que
l'ancien président malien se sentait en
danger est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
peur pour l'intégrité physique tout
faire très attention bien sûr et là
encore on ne peut pas admettre que
violence
règle des questions elle n'aurait jamais
sur le fond les questions la ruse les
questions que vous posez seront
parfaitement légitime mais doivent
s'adresser à l'exécutif la rue la russie
l'autre grand dossier cyril on sait
c'est cette frise ukrainienne qui n'en
finit pas avec des accusations des états
unis notamment et de l'otan de menaces
d'invasion de la russie sur son voisin
ukrainien il ya déjà eu un conflit a
déjà deux républiques autoproclamées non
reconnus dans le donbass la crime a été
annexé en 2014 on a le sentiment et
envoie vladimir poutine à l'image il l'a
dit lui même les européens c'est trop de
blabla il a dit le président russe moi
je discute avec les américains où est
l'europe dans cette crise oui mais vous
avez à l'esprit puisque vous êtes
spécialisé question qu'il y avait
auparavant un processus dit de minsk où
nous discutions nous les français avec
les allemands et avec les rues
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le format
normandie reprend à paris un fondement
normandie alors aujourd'hui les
américains sont également intégrés et et
d'autre mais même si ça vous surprend je
revenais un instant en arrière sur la
question climatique et la question
énergétique
parce que tout est lié vous allez au gaz
voilà vous avez vu que les prix des
énergies classiques sont en train de
monter considérablement ce qui est posé
problème du pouvoir d'achat groupé en
france mais on dit que ça ne s'arrêtera
pas et on dit que ce serait papa or si
nous sommes dans cette situation c'est
que nous sommes extrêmement dépendant
justement tu vas juste là encore c'est
impressionnant sert ce sont les états
unis hier qui disent on va essayer de
garantir aux européens d'avoir du gaz
comme si les européens étaient un peu
vassaliser par rapport aux gaz une fête
de fait regarder l'ensemble du tableau
actuellement une grande partie de nos
importations de gaz vient précisément de
la russie et c'est encore plus important
pour nos amis allemands ce qui signifie
que si à terme pas dans l'immédiat nous
voulons une indépendance plus grande de
l'europe et singulièrement la france
c'est lié aussi à ce que nous serons
capables de faire sur le plan
énergétique et on revient à la question
climatique non merci moi benkaci
présentateur du 64 minutes le monde en
français et de magath orient-express
d'où vos questions aussi à laurent
fabius le président du conseil
constitutionnel depuis la réunion
enfin bus franck dubray de ouest-france
à une question à vous poser vous qu'elle
avait été gelée rappelé tout à leur
premier ministre à 38 ans écoute bonjour
monsieur fabius à vanessa miranville
maire de la possession à la réunion vous
qui avez été le plus jeune premier
ministre de la vème république
quel est le secret de votre longévité
politique
mais je ne fais plus de politique donc
on a très bien vu sur ce plateau sera la
leur la longévité elle est assurée mais
pas la longévité politique non le sens
de votre question c'est
ce qu' il est normal d'avoir des
carrières très longue si j'ai commencé
très tôt c'est pas à cause de mes
mérites exceptionnels c'est que ça va
vous paraître antédiluvien mais je suis
devenu pour la première fois un ministre
en 1981 au moment de l'alternance et
pourquoi moi qui était à l'époque très
jeune chevelu ministre budget n'ont pas
voilà qu'ils n'ont pas et est ensuite
premier ministre non pas parce que
j'étais un génie mais parce que
toute la gauche n'avait pas été au
pouvoir depuis des décennies et donc
personne n'avait de l'expérience sous
françois mitterrand mais ce qui l'était
pris puisqu'il était président la
république et donc à cette époque
la gauche a été amené à donner des
responsabilités à des gens très très
jeune et c'est pour ça que ce qui
advient d'habitude quand on a à 45 50
ans 50 50 60 ans pour moi c'est arrivé
quand j'avais vous avez le sentiment
d'être d'être entré dans l'histoire de
la vème république avec vos formes eu
par exemple on se rappelle de lui c'est
lui moi c'est moi qui fait encore le
bonheur de certains politiques
aujourd'hui oui enfin il ya beaucoup
d'autres questions en particulier je me
rappelle mes ce site en terre que
j'avais dit que telle ou telle formation
apporter de mauvaises réponses mais à de
bonnes questions pour nationale je
n'étais pas totalement faux mais la
partie l'international
c'était une époque passée non je vais
pas commenter les propres formules alors
ça ce serait ce serait complètement
déplacé mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de chance dans ma
vie et maintenant
je suis sortie de la politique mais je
dois faire en sorte que mon expérience
soit utile à la préservation de nos
libertés et à l'affirmation que la
france est un pays de droit voudrait
faire quoi après fabius après vous
voulez dire à 90 ans en dix ans 150 ans
bon
écoute et vous avez encore quatre ans de
mandat je rappelle trois ans trois bons
quant à willy brandt qui était un grand
chancelier d'allemagne
qui a mené la conciliation je veux
laisser l'ouest
approchait de la fin de sa vie ce n'est
pas mon cas j'espère on lui a demandé
mais une chance unique qu'est ce que
vous voudriez qu'on met sur votre tombe
c'est pas très gai ce que je dis mais la
réponse est intéressante il dit je
voudrais qu'on inscrive ces mots j'ai
fait mon possible
merci laurent faire c'est en fabriquant
du conseil constitutionnel d'avoir été
invité de face aux territoires ce matin
sur tv5 monde et pourra me continue dans
un instant sur cette chaîne francophone
mondiale au revoir à tous merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]